[Music]
just 45 minutes north of the u.s border
is a city called langley it's a typical
city
there's a casino tree-lined streets
and of course a ghanaian tribal chief
this is eric manu he works in langley as
a gardener for this woman susan watson
in canada yard work is a year-round
occupation you'd be surprised how busy
we are during the winter
[Music]
back to eric eric's story began with a
phone call last july yeah my uncle died
and i got a call to take over that
responsibility as a chief of my
community i don't see abba number two he
said something like really are you
kidding me
i said i'm gonna give it a try
so he went back to ghana and became
chief but he decided to return to
langley and this is when susan got
involved and where our contemporary
story begins everything that happened
after eric became chief i have seen so
much in canada as my own experience and
i also want my people to have some kind
of opportunity
in life
with susan eric is working on raising
funds and collecting donations to help
set up medical clinics for his tribe to
improve education
overall he's trying to make life better
for his people back home
we started the to the moon and back
foundation to
help the people in ghana we've collected
more than two 20-foot containers full of
donated items
my journey has been a very successful
journey
although i'm a chief in ghana i'm proud
working as a gardener to support and
give my people the exposure i'm proud of
my community i'm proud of my family and
i'm proud to be an african and i'm proud
to be a ghanaian
[Music]
you